when i landed in san francisco i was
like [ __ ] this air sucks
like i'm breathing it in i'm like oh my
god the pollution how can you tell the
pollution levels
when you breathe in when i land in the
[ __ ] country i step off the plane i
take a
deep breath and i'm like this as [ __ ]
why is this insane
it literally sounds like the stupidest
superpower
gentlemen i let me i i have the intro
for this right gentlemen
what if i told you you could get anime
for free
for free gentlemen are we [ __ ]
jumping right into it because
that's gonna be the first topic for
today but right now i have with me the
boys god and joey and i
am monkeys you didn't even say hello you
just you just like [ __ ] opened up
with this that's like
everything sales people like illuminati
conspiracy theory
every good sales pitch starts with the
hook literally reminded me of that wolf
of wall street
sell me this pen because you know now
they're listening
they're intrigued how can we get free
animation what a hook
they don't want to know about trash
taste they want to know why
i said free anime i wasn't stumbling
tell me more salesman who's totally not
shady well if you just go to the
kickstarter page
we're going to talk about that we're
going to talk about anime is that what
it's called
what's the first topic today uh two
weeks ago we want to talk about this
last week but chris came on
inconvenience stars again we would have
spoken about this last week because we
wanted to talk about anime tube we know
chris goes into fits when we talk about
it so
we're gonna be like three weeks late but
the whole the bottle is kind of finished
now yeah talking about that we have all
the info
like it like lived and died within the
span of a day
i think yes pretty much it was very
interesting essentially what happened is
uh this thing called anime tube popped
up on kickstarter
and yeah offered to give all the kind uh
anyone really yeah free anime free anime
and you're probably thinking well you
know they probably only got like you
know c rate shows yeah
yeah yeah yeah really terrible now what
do they have they they said they were
gonna
they were in talks to get evangelion
love hina which has been stuck in
copyright halibut knock up right now
licensing specifically love hina i don't
know i don't know
who like just specifically picks lafina
attack on titan format alchemist even
though these were already all on
streaming platforms already yeah you
know and i imagine that the ones that
aren't have been out of print for the
past
twenty they say zero as well uh i didn't
i didn't see the list
they've got everything it's animate
shoes you know i mean you know and so i
i can't
i don't know how much these properties
are worth but i can't i can't imagine
you getting evangelion for less than
like 100 million or something ridiculous
you know probably sounds absurd but
it's probably worth that much right yeah
so clearly these guys are big bucks to
spend around i mean i'm just glad
a company is giving the power back to
the people and taking on small indie
companies like
so [ __ ] license holders yeah so taking
on small indie companies like
sony and att you know like you know
someone's going to take these what were
they going to do what were they going to
do with it so yeah so
essentially this kickstarter promised
that and it and it raised in like one
day
like 110 000 yeah it literally came out
nowhere because i remember we were we
literally came in the trash taste studio
in the morning
and then it was just all over my twitter
timeline i was like what the hell was
going on
and we all looked at it and we were just
like wait this kickstarter
launched yesterday and it's raised over
a hundred thousand dollars
promising people free anime legally and
i'm just like
what is going on right now it was an
absolute disaster
april was about three months ago guys
like
you're a bit late to the joke right now
yeah it was just uh
a mess it was hilarious it was a mess
the the you know i think it it's so many
levels to it
there's so many things that are really
sad about it one um
you know i think it's safe to say that
this was uh
either the most over ambitious
kickstarter of all time
yeah uh or it was uh they were lying
all the most genius scam now yeah i mean
you know you have to be careful when you
say these guys because you can get uh
sued so trying to get trash take suit
here jerry okay but from what i i i saw
yeah it's
a scam
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah well i mean i'm protecting myself
i'm not going to say the s
word but uh i'm going to say that it
looked very sus
i'll say the other little sassy scam
it's a sassy bucket is what it is you
know i genuinely wonder because
you know again they promised to have all
these titles that
there's absolutely you know not even
netflix or amazon can get all of these
shows right
this is some serious amount of cash and
negotiating power
that i doubt a kickstarter would be able
to convince the japanese
investors flicks and like sony can't
even get the rights to some of these
yeah what what suggests to anyone that
this kickstarter group will be able to
like evangelion literally couldn't be
even been out of print for the past 20
years you couldn't get the license trip
until netflix somehow
probably don't even want to know how
much netflix is playing for that oh no
the creator didn't even have the rights
to it for the longest time until i had
to [ __ ] fight with guy naxx to get
back
it's insanity yeah i mean the thing is i
think
there's as you said there's so many
layers to it because you know in theory
it's a nice idea you know having
somewhere where you can watch anime
legally
feels bad because we're like laughing at
they're like imagine trying to take on
the big guy hahaha funny
yeah but but like if it was a good
attempt i would be yeah right
right if it was a good attempt but like
keep in mind you're taking on like
companies like sony like netflix you
know like like
people who you know have have a bit of
dollar in their pocket you know
and like yeah i i don't think we're
trying to be like yeah we love
corporations and stuff like that because
i
i feel like a lot of this was driven by
you know the people's hatred
towards corporations and you know i get
it you know if you don't want to support
the big corporations
because of whatever reason you know i
get it but there's there's a difference
between
not wanting to support like big
corporations and then like
supporting like whatever this is yeah
right it's blindly accepting anything
it's like not wanting
it's like not wanting to buy paracetamol
for your pharmacy so you go to like the
local drug dealer
you know like like what's the yeah yeah
i guess
it's like it's like betting in a horse
race but the horse's two legs that's why
i felt so kind of just sad about it
really i felt sad that there was
enough weebs out there that were this
desperate to like stick it to the carpet
it's like yeah
they would throw that money into a void
dude weebs want free [ __ ] man
at the end of the day this is also what
i don't understand is that we have weebs
that are this dedicated to say [ __ ] you
to companies
that are willing to give money away but
you could they could just
pirate if they really want to really get
it for free i'm not saying you should
i i condone that do not do it but
i mean it's also like you're kind of
basically composing i mean it's also
like
the money that they gave to this
kickstarter right because like there
were a lot of people who are giving like
hundreds of dollars to this kickstarter
and like some some people i saw were
giving literally thousands of people
yeah i mean there was starter when i
looked there was
a thousand backers giving a hundred
thousand so it's
rough on average a hundred dollars each
given a lot of money that's like
you know a year's subscription yeah to
netflix
but it's not what the message i'm
sending
it's about sending a message the message
of i got scammed
yeah well i mean it's it's the it's the
thing is where
if anyone just like literally used a
single brain cell
like you think about like the logistics
of this
the logistics like just the logistics of
why this
would not work in the first place or
like you know a hundred thousand seems
like a lot of money
to like any normal person it's like a
drop in the [ __ ] bucket
for like anime licensing features and
all that stuff
you can maybe license half an episode no
no not even that
you can maybe license the thumbnail
about an image half an episode of like a
c to your
much yeah anime i mean yeah like we and
what surprised me is that they were
the shows that they were listing as the
shows they were going for
what like the [ __ ] triple a titles
that
are worth millions and millions of
dollars right i mean god knows how much
netflix actually paid to get evangelion
out of licensing hell because evangelion
was out of like life
couldn't be licensed by any western
company for like feels
like a decade literally since it was
made yeah yeah like since since like
since adv like collapsed i can't think
of any other
like company that has successfully
licensed evangelion
and i think people like to think of
anime still this kind of underground
thing but some of these shows are easily
you know worth over hundreds of millions
of dollars like these types
right like i think the merchandising of
these shows as well right think about
like the ips shows i think about the
mega shows like any of the shonen jump
shows like my hero
how much does attack on titanfall
[ __ ] demonstrate yeah right
i mean a billion dollar property yeah
yeah exactly it's already proven to be
that yeah so i
it's really i just i don't understand
like every
none of this i who were these thousands
of people who gave money like i
legitimately wanted that yeah i
legitimately want to know
it's obviously very young impressionable
anime fans right who are just
hoping for this yeah society right i
wonder if some parts of it we're just
completely like oblivious about like
we take for granted some of them like
because we yeah i mean we work with
japanese companies we know how these
things are
you can't go around saying you're in
talks that is that is like the biggest
no-no in business
like and especially here i feel like
it's never a done deal until it's done
dealing
did you read the faq what was that that
what do they say
oh okay i read some of it what was the
do you remember the thing about
licensing or something yeah
i remember like one of the faqs uh one
of the questions was uh
isn't anime licensing really expensive
yes
and they they legit went um actually
um anime licensing isn't as expensive as
everyone makes it out to be
the only reason nobody does it and
nobody talks about it is because of ndas
but
we are in talks with real japanese anime
licenses
and uh that was pretty much that was
pretty much the answer to the question
can they get anime licenses they
literally just shot themselves in the
foot they just
they didn't have to answer that question
you can't say you're talking to these
companies like it's
very also it's all very secretive you
know yeah intentionally so
all these companies are like yeah do you
know this guy yeah
yeah because there was a guy there was a
so they also uh i think the
person uh i'm not sure the ceo someone
representing right stuff
anime yeah yeah which is the american
company i think which uh buys the
licenses for
again i'm not sure either way they they
buy a license or they sell or they sell
dvds
they reached out being like uh so
apparently you've listed some of our
titles
uh and you say that we're in talks and
the guy tweeted him saying that we've
never been in talks
and then they replied saying we sent you
a message on linkedin
that was there we're in talks i'm in
[ __ ] talks with all the people that
email me about weird [ __ ] then oh no
what the [ __ ]
it's just like bro bro i dm'd you why
didn't you dm back i see you my linkedin
dm please respond
we're in talks now right hundreds of
millions of dollars are at stake because
of my linkedin i sent you a dm please
give me
um the anime license please give me the
ips that's that's
they haven't responded yet but we're in
talks we're working on an arrangement
it's just insanity we're part of this
one-sided conversation it was just
it was just it all burned down in flames
luckily but yeah yeah
it was just oh my god it was such a it
was just so bizarre to see and
you know we knew it was gonna like come
down in flames yeah i mean
i think right now it's like been taken
off kickstarter right
as far as i can so yeah okay
it's still there but but the funding is
stopped
oh okay so so now i'm going to give them
anymore
that's good okay that's good okay okay
so yeah it is so kick start suspended
111 000 yeah i like i don't know how
true this is but i did see a screenshot
i might
prop up my timeline the other day though
that uh shows that they haven't given up
they've started like a newsletter which
you can
they which you can subscribe to for a
dollar
so for a dollar for this newsletter you
can subscribe for updates
people are just taking updates of what
talks in the end
i don't know i legit don't know and it's
like it is like on this week's
newsletter
we're in talks with adv trying to get
the right it's just it's just absolutely
tragic
like it's obvious that you know i'm not
being funny but there's a reason why
like
netflix doesn't have its own discord
server as well they had their own
discord
server and they started banning people
and it's like what is this
this is [ __ ] yandere devs game what
is this this is like
what's going on here it's so obvious
because they've done this like two times
before yeah as well and they failed
twice
i saw they've made other kids so so
they're trying to make this kickstarter
this is their third attempt
and i think another app similar to it
popped up
on the microsoft store and was taken
down before as well so yeah
they have a history of doing this and
failing and whatever but clearly
you know every time it comes around it
seems to get some money so i
i guess why not i guess i got some real
balls to do it like three or four times
no shame man
i'm sorry if you [ __ ] gave money to
that kickstarter like
yeah i mean like like i i would say like
i like the idea no
intentions yeah intentions aside i like
the idea of it
everybody wishes for it i mean everyone
everybody wishes for because i feel like
you know
in the era we're we're in now i think
like we're past the golden age of
streaming
because we'll pass the point in time
where you could get
every show that you've physically
feasibly watched on one platform and
it's unfortunate that that's the case um
but it's kind of evolved into
like a similar era to what the cable era
was like
but i mean when p when corporations
started to realize that there was money
in streaming this was
this was going to be the way that things
were going to evolve unfortunately
because
unfortunately money talks you know and
if there could be a platform where
every anime you ever watch was on a
single platform i'm sure someone would
have done that already
you know i'm sure someone with a lot of
money would have done that already i
hate to be the bearer of bad news but
anime is a business
streaming is one of those people is
where it's nigh on impossible to get
into it unless you've got like
yeah massive investors yeah like maybe
maybe like 10 15 years ago
that's good maybe you know if you at the
start of the
streaming age like when crunchyroll
first started but like that time's past
now you can't just you can't just be
like the little guy
taking on the big guy anymore oh yeah
it's like quibby as well i had like what
like six billion dollars yeah
exactly
it was made it was founded by the guy
who uh left disney and founded
dreamworks
uh come from his name um and made quibby
a streaming service
and it was an absolute dumpster
but it had like billions of dollars in
investments
but it disappeared after like two weeks
right or something well it was like you
got a free trial then you had to pay
and like it literally just tanked like
immediately yeah yeah yeah like and but
they they
paid for so many original shows as well
they're just wait who's on there
i don't [ __ ] know i i didn't go on i
didn't i didn't yeah
i didn't even know about this oh yeah
yeah how did you know about this a
couple of years ago i think was it a
couple of years ago
was like two years ago i think yeah no
it was like a year ago was it i think it
might i don't [ __ ] up
it's a recent map i don't even count
last year last year frankly just flew by
i i can't i can't remember anything did
that happen 2019 it was a year ago yeah
i'm still 22 as far as i'm concerned
[ __ ] king crimson like existed in
2020
and just like [ __ ] erased the entire
year and we just skipped it literally
felt like last month
was like april 2020. this is really
weird
yeah i mean we're already halfway
through 2021 which is terrifying didn't
mixer die as well
yeah mixer died oh yeah yeah man [ __ ] i
wish i got offered to move to mixer
i'd have got a nice cash out and ninja's
just like set for life and
he's the only reason anyone knows about
mixer i think
um but like yeah i mean like even with
those failed platforms they had like
millions and billions of dollars
invested into them by angel investors
yeah they definitely weren't started by
[ __ ] kickstarter
yeah yeah and and unfortunately like
even if you have like
what's what what would be like the most
successful kickstarter of all time
what what i don't know what's like
that's very telling that we can't think
of one
yeah i'm sure there is some good ones
out there i just i
i've never been interested yeah to get
pursued any good kickstarter you can
just buy the thing when it [ __ ] comes
out yeah
yeah yeah and and because i'm just
thinking with the money that with the
money that
kickstarter can be people can invest
into kickstarter even like the most
successful kickstarter of all time would
probably have trouble
getting into the streaming field the
only one i remember
was those like sunglasses that had the
built-in headphones into it
remember those that was successful there
was a kickstarter i remember it because
it was like during
my uni days but there was this there's
this pair of sunglasses where on the
brim
here it was like this new technology and
audio where
it would vibrate and the vibrations
would travel
through your ears and the music will
come into yours and i remember it was a
successful kickstarter i was like
millions of dollars
but that's not successful yeah but is
that the most successful kickstarter of
all time
is the most success are you kidding me
nabi number eight
oh number eight the who yeah is like how
much money did the ouya raise
uh eight million five hundred ninety six
thousand eight yeah but you gotta bear
in mind right even if even if someone
raised
20 million
even if somebody raised 200 300 million
dollars that doesn't mean
[ __ ] for streaming you can't you can't
buy much with that
no that's what that's what i'm trying to
say like even with the most successful
kickstarters of all time
to get into this field you need external
investors
if if they really want to challenge the
big guys you know because there's a
there's a lot of money in there right
was it broke yeah
you could gather all the anime fans in
the wall and it probably won't even be
enough don't understand people can
invest in kickstarter after like it's
just track record it's just
poorly have you ever donated to a
kickstarter no why you saved like 20
and you got to put 100 in for some [ __ ]
and it's like i'll just wait till it
comes out
i've done i've done a few but not like
the stupid amount of money that some
people like
every time i look at a kickstarter and i
see like the you know the top tiers
which are like
a thousand ten thousand dollars and you
see like one left two left i'm like who
are these people
because they're just dropping ten
thousand dollars for stuff that
genuinely needs the money i would be
more inclined like a game or something
that i like i'm into i would but
i haven't though but yeah most of the
time the stuff that gets the most is
just like [ __ ] pre-orders essentially
you're just
the products made they know what they're
doing and you're just pre-ordering yeah
i mean with kickstarter i feel like if
it's a small indie project or something
that you can see
feasibly getting funded on kickstarter
yeah i would support it i mean i
i think the last kick starter i
supported was actually uh the
trigger anime i think they funded
the second ova of like little witch
academy yeah yeah yeah i supported that
yeah
that makes sense to me that seems like a
like this is why kickstarter should
exist
yeah yeah but like if you're if you're
coming in trying to change like
stir up an entire industry or whatever
kickstarter is just not going to do it
anymore i think kickstarter is really
good for
you know a small indie team to do some
kind of project
like a [ __ ] industry changing project
you need something else
usually kickstarters is for like you
know like kind of it stops at an
artistic level right
it's not really the thing that you go
into to be like
i'm gonna cause a scene in the in the
industry you know [ __ ] everything on
kickstarter is the same
[ __ ] it's like all right get the stock
image of people running
play the play the music mood and the the
the you know the you know the
the ukulele on that one or like there's
always there's always some like
motivational thing and then it's just
like
have you ever had this problem that
isn't a problem well now we can solve it
and then it looks amazing and then you
think about it like it's all [ __ ]
it's always it's always the same type of
people that are kick-started too isn't
it yeah it's always like the way to
overly enthusiastic like
my name is kyle it'll be either it'll
either be someone from california or
someone from eastern europe
yeah like with a really thick accent
explaining why
his fridge is the best fridge and it's
like okay
that's cool that's fine i just don't
want it with our last project the
walking fridge
we raised two hundred thousand dollars
that's insane i just i just realized
that kickstarters are basically the
modern infomercials
yeah i just don't believe
any any any single advertisement
where someone gives it to a random
person
and they're like whoa it's amazing i
just don't believe that i if even if it
actually happens
i just don't want i don't i don't even
believe it when there's another thing
which says like not a paid actor yeah
you sure about that oh you did you said
go back to anime tube
did you see the [ __ ] testimonials
they had
i think they just got like some random
people they found on discord to give
them testimonials of that app or
something like that
it's good what was the testimonial
let me let me let me see let me see let
me see if i can bring it up right now
but uh yeah i mean it's it's all it's
all the same right it's
literally yeah it's just like you know
i frankly don't really do i don't trust
anyone who shows me their review just
let me see your reviews i'll have a look
it is routinely maintained it's
comfortable it's quite
logical and ergonomic it's way beyond
any competition
i like it of course it's beyond the
[ __ ] competition when you can just
take the licenses
like rip them off a dvd the best app for
on hand anime i used to spend days
looking up series
but now i just use this app with ease
thank you robert
thank you stefan roberts and james
with the most rudimentary anime profile
pictures i've ever seen yeah i mean it's
it's just
it's like we're going to look back on
this and it's just going to feel like a
fever dream
you know i yeah whatever it it already
does
it's [ __ ] stupid don't do that this
episode is sponsored by
honey guys we all shop online and we've
all seen that promo code feel
taunt us at the checkout but thanks to
honey manually searching for coupons
like a peasant
is the thing of the past honey is a free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes
and applies the best one it finds to
your cards it supports over
30 000 stores online right now
that's a lot of stores that's incredible
all right boys hear me here
imagine you're shopping on your favorite
site okay and when you're at the
checkout the honey button
drops down and all you have to do is
click apply coupons you wait a few
seconds
as honey searches for its coupons you
can find for that site and if honey
finds a working coupon
you'll watch those prices joey stop
seducing me like this i can't hear these
words right now
i'm literally coming i recently bought a
new pair of noise-canceling headphones
and thanks to honey i saved
20. and i'm not the only honey member
making savings there's over 17
million members getting those sweet
savings worth two billion dollars if you
don't already have honey you could be
straight up missing out on
free savings it's literally free and
just takes a few seconds
and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a favor and you'll be
supporting us as well
i'd never recommend something i don't
use so get honey for free at
joinhoney.comtaste that's jointhoney.com
links in the description below back to
the episode i don't trust reviews on
websites that aren't like
a third party's website you know what i
mean even some third-party websites
right like even amazon they're all
[ __ ] right like and especially if it's
on your website
no i don't trust your review five stars
no way it's on your website i just don't
trust amazon reviews in general like
especially in japan
there's i mean we've talked about this
before right yeah but
i mean that's why uh they have like the
certified seller thing certified uh
buyer
yeah bought it which makes more sense
yeah um we need more people like melin
with the hard opinions
i'm a [ __ ] reviewer because i don't
really give a [ __ ] as long as it does
the thing
i i don't care some people could have
you know written a review for like you
know something or anything
yeah i'm always five or one star i'm
that guy i'm that kind of guy
because that's the tim might see me it
either works or it does yeah
and like if it looks fine fine that's it
if it does the thing i paid for it to do
five stars that's great
those [ __ ] were like two out of ten
the box was bruised
like people people like rate furniture
and they're they're like it was
complicated to build
uh two stars and i'm like but that's
truly that's just like that's on you bro
yeah i feel like that's that's a
interpretation thing like is the thing
good yeah at the end of the day you're
only going to build it for like one hour
or two hours or so there are some times
when i'm just like how
like i'm pretty sure you need a phd to
translate okay this
is the instruction manual that they gave
every item there's just like one
thing i know what you mean but at the
same time like my okay i have a coffee
table right now that was
so over engineered and the amount of
screws and [ __ ] for it was
totally stupid yeah that was three hours
out of like the two years i've been
using it
i don't give a [ __ ] about those three
hours looking back now that's why i
write the review like three months after
i get it because then i'm like
oh yeah it's good it's just still
standing that's why i wait if it breaks
after like one month all right fine but
that's one star i shouldn't have broke
one month if i use it but like
people these people who write it and
they're like um the cardboard box was
slightly damaged you know the furniture
took a little longer than i'd like to it
like
[ __ ] off the delivery man had a bad
attitude like [ __ ]
it's got nothing to do with anything and
then as well even if it breaks i'm like
all right how long reasonably did i
expect it to last
like my bed's broken is that but it's
two years is that
he also spent like 100 bucks on it it
was 300 bucks for the mattress and the
bed
which is very cheap for a bed
considering how much we've spent
uh like on amazon to get like our first
furniture i think
the furniture i have right now has
lasted very well um
my bed is like the this design of this
bed is when i was building that i'm like
huh this doesn't seem
super structurally stable i understand
why i was three stars now yeah yeah yeah
well basically you know that meme with
the cheeto in the door holding the
door closed there's like a tiny plank
like a piece of plywood
that basically is like holding up the
middle of the bed and like all the way
on it
that doesn't sound safe no and uh
when you stood on that and jumped on it
would just crack right well one time i
i think i like just like like because i
don't know i i wouldn't say i get into
bed aggressively yeah
but i'm not like i'm not polite about it
you're not gonna be like
i'm not like i'm not like like sneaking
into my bed you know i just kind of like
you know just
[ __ ] lady beard and just like [ __ ]
does a clothesline on the bed or
something like that
boom no so i just like
plopped on my bed and i just heard the
boom and then and then i like looked
under my bed and this thing had just
like
like [ __ ] went lit to the side and i
was like oh that's our [ __ ] no no
it's literally just like
put in with the weight it's just a plank
of like like literally like if this is
the bed
make sure i don't trip the like it's
just like this you just got to like
center this piece of wood
it's literally like this size as well oh
my god and so when i when i
i looked and it was like this i was just
like oh sorry so i'm just like
[Music]
so i do that every time it does it now i
mean that's that that works right
new bed yeah probably time for a new
bird i mean you're moving soon gonna
yeah i'm gonna upgrade
your breads which bread my breasts
upgrading my breasts i'll do it from
white to rice
yeah i'll obviously like you can feel
the springs on it and everything right
now can't you i kind of like filling the
springs though why
really it's got a nice feel to it you
know i don't know does that mean there's
no one else someone someone else is like
i like feeling a little bit of something
like people looking around the room not
a single person is like
yeah it sounds like that sounds like
peasant talk to me okay i'm
[Music]
sure
wants to feel the springs on the bread
connor stop saying
what is your obsession with bread yes i
don't want springs in my [ __ ] bread
that would be really awkward when i'm
trying to cut it um the knife keeps
bouncing
it's just slinky well
i you know when i go to a hotel i have
their amazing
you know [ __ ] whatever the little
hippo is the brand i don't know what it
is sleep easy
anti-gravity mattress or whatever the
[ __ ] it's the hippo it's like sleep easy
the brand i think it's a hippo
brand it's like some deluxe divine
10 000 sheep i'm like oh that's pretty
good this it's great that
but also those beds are ridiculous and
like i don't
i don't think they're that much better
than a shitty bed
i don't know i don't know about that one
chief
you know you know a [ __ ] mattress when
you're on it yeah i i had a i had a
memory foam one at my
parents house i don't like memory foam
ones those ones i don't like
so yeah i love those when i first well
yeah it's because you gotta break it in
like you really
like after like a year it's like amazing
it's like putty you just like
sink yourself it takes like months for
it to like actually get the right shape
but then it's amazing
i want to like feel some bounce on it
with with the memory foam one it feels
like i'm sleeping in quicksand
where you just sink in and you're just
like oh yeah that's the thing though
like the comfort envelopes
but i feel like the thing is you know i
mean uh i feel like that's like
admitting you're just single if you get
a memory foam one
because it's like it's not it's not an
exciting bed you know
what do you mean do i need to explain
god please there's no bounce
i got chances right i mean it's just
depressing it's it's it's
it's like [ __ ] on a bean bag you know
i mean i don't i don't use memory foam
beds so
you go then you know what i mean i like
the bounce i mean i like to bounce
normally when i'm sleeping
you know what are you [ __ ] sleeping
like this
you can like rebound them
i need some balance when i'm fighting my
sleep paralysis
get do i up need to explain this come on
i get it i get it sometimes you know
sometimes you just want to play a bit of
basketball right
just want to dribble some balls
sometimes you need to like dribble you
know what i mean
can you catch my drift guys
but like spring breads are like awful
for that they they're they are
good you can use this same bread
didn't i you literally said stupid
have you ever slept on a water bed
before i imagine i imagine that must be
fun
that's really fun it's like literally is
that actually fun is it comfortable
it's really okay i find it to be super
[ __ ] comfortable but that's because
again it's like
it's but i find memory foam to be really
comfortable so it's kind of like that
because like
the the mattress kind of follows you as
you're moving around
but then like if you're if you're like
in a if you're like you become the
mattress you get a double memory foam
mattress so
you guys are like never going to touch
each other you guys are going to be like
we have our we have our crevice it is
set
yeah that's why that's what i don't like
about memory foam mattresses that's
right
it's a single like a single bed there's
no movement i'm not seeing enough
movement
anywhere on a memory foam mattress you
sink in and that's just it
that's what that's what couples do when
they like agree that they're just not
having sex anymore like that's
that's what that is true everything so
let me just sink into my car yeah
because you have your
you literally if your memory foam is
like set you it's so uncomfortable
to move to a position where it isn't set
what about what about memory foam
pillows
oh yeah i like the pillows yeah do you
like the pillows nah
i i like feeling that i like it i like a
little resistance i like a little bounce
on like whatever i'm [ __ ] the
pillowcard
i like when the pillow fights yeah
i think the pillow needs like a little
bit of firmness i like when the pillow's
at scenario you know like
if you see if you're sinking too much
then i feel like being able to like you
know if i'm
kind of just not happy with the pillow i
can just like punch the [ __ ] out of this
yeah
yeah literally until you're like all
right it is refreshed
yeah because you guys sometimes you
could just you just gotta [ __ ]
tenderize the pillow right you [ __ ]
gonna get the [ __ ] steak tenderizer
all right now it's perfect i used to i
used to use two pillows exclusively but
now for some reason i can't use two is
that like getting old is that an old
no i've i've actually gone the opposite
i used to be able to sleep on one pillow
but now i need two
i can't do two anymore it has to be one
what i don't know
maybe because my when i was a child uh
when i was a child sorry my mom already
bought
the shittest thinnest pillows maybe that
was why ah so i was like yeah i always
sleep with two and i'm like this
yo i always stick with two pillows no i
was the opposite like i had like the
really really thin pillows right and we
couldn't afford another pillow so
i think that's why yeah i think that's
why i had two so i was like why am i
waking up with a headache every morning
oh it's because all the blood is rushing
to my head
like this japan has these pillows that
you get in like hotels and stuff that i
hate
which ones like double-sided ones yeah
um but
but double-sided pillows double-sided no
no so like that there's two different
types of material on each side
and one of them is literally like solid
bean bag like it's like a bean bag that
you have to like
physically like move around it's the
sand one right yeah it's horrible
i love it and it's like sticking into
your neck it's now what yeah what
i love like you know when you're like
sleeping on a futon like the the sand
pillows that you get on i know i hate
those give me something soft i love
those because it again like it gives me
that
perfect height where it makes me sleep
so well did you just say sand pillows
it's it feels like saying it's like a
speed yeah
rock solid though yeah it's it's like if
you packed a
a bean bag a little with too much beans
yeah i stayed in a hotel one time and i
was like when i left i was like [ __ ]
that that [ __ ]
that was horrible oh you just flipped it
like what
i didn't know that you can just most of
them are two-sided so the other side
will be like a normal pillow oh i always
just like go to the hotel just touch the
sand side i'm like dude
i'm satisfied i'll take it i hate the
sand maybe because i used to sleep with
those at my grandma's place
that's all she had she might it just
makes me feel like i'm in a hospital i
don't know why
hospital but the hospitals have like the
super like pillows that kind of go
out like this right
i don't know i don't think i've never
stayed in hospital
you've never stayed in a hospital no
i've stayed in a hospital
once i'm trying to remember if i have i
definitely have it's just
it's not a common occurrence obviously
but
maybe i have some time in my childhood
i'm just taking a weekly trip to the
hospital which is casual it's a free
hotel in the uk if you get injured
have you ever like injured you have you
ever like been to the hospital like
with an injury and stuff like that have
you ever talked about that like you've
injured yourself so bad that you had to
go to the hospital
not like breaking a bone or anything
i've i've never had any bad injuries i
don't think
um no you i had once like i have like
stitches
but you can still kind of see it right
right there on my finger um that was the
only time
because like i fell when i was like two
years old and i landed
like kind of like my hands like that and
a piece of glass just went
straight into there so they had to pull
it out and give me stitches but that's
about it really that wasn't boring yeah
that was really fun
drink my milk bro i've had some pretty
bad injuries but something i've never
had like never been like i've always
been like walking off or get off
just your arms falling i probably have
like broken my toe or something i'm just
not knowing about it you know
that's pretty common i feel like it's
pretty common i've sprained my wrists
yeah it was from like i think i told the
story when i failed like a jump scheme
snowboarding right and that was [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah yeah i thought i was gonna
die but i was like
that's i'll snowboard it off i'll
snowboard i was just kept snowboarding
when i was winded that's how you know
we're inside kids when we haven't like
broken any bones or anything what are
you expecting joey we're [ __ ] like i
don't know man
you're [ __ ] anime nerds and gamers
i've been very lucky
wanting yourself so hard you dislocate
your wrist or something i don't know i
think about all the injuries i've had
and how i've just
never had any damage from it i'm like
that's very lucky tipped a quad bike
when i was like 10 on myself
and you didn't go to the hospital i
wasn't injured at all jesus hipped a
quad bike on yourself yeah how'd you do
that
i tipped a quad bike so my uh because
you know
my mate owned a farm and i love getting
his house because it's just basically
like a free theme park
yeah and farms are great when you're
yeah because it's like everything's just
a quad bike and he had a quad bike yeah
and his dad
didn't give a [ __ ] he was just like you
need to go on the quad bike right so you
just let us go on the quad bike
um and i i i was like uh one of those
like [ __ ] danger addicts when i was
like a 10 year old i just wanted to like
do dangerous things
yeah so uh my friend he was used to
going on the quad bike
and uh he was just like yeah it's all
right just don't go too fast and i was
like all right
immediately went too fast i'm like i was
just turning really really fast
and when i was going so fast the bike
just went like oh
it just flipped over jesus did like a
barrel roll but i i
so it like tipped and i think i was
small enough where like i don't i don't
know how it happened but it tipped
yeah i sneaked into the guy i didn't get
hurt at all and i just got up
and the bar was a little [ __ ] on the
thing but we like hit it into place and
it was good and then i went back on it
you went back on it yeah i would not
[ __ ] go back on it
i was like yeah dude that was so fun
let's do it again almost died let's do
it again
yeah i haven't mentioned like have you
guys had any near-death experiences
before
i told the story about how i'd like got
launched with a bounce castle right
yes oh yeah that was probably one as
well yeah cause i remember i
remember telling you this uh like a few
days ago but uh i think the nearest
death experience i had was like
the most probably the most lamest story
i could tell yeah but uh it was during a
snowball fight
right so so in university
uh in england we don't get lost though
we get like snow once or twice a year
right
right and so anytime it snows everyone
takes the opportunity to play around in
the snow and in university
what that means is we just go out and
have a bunch of snowball fights right
so it was uh like one dorm versus
another dorm and we were like
having a snowball fight in the middle of
this like residential area in bristol
right so it wasn't like in the middle of
a field or something it was literally
like on the roads and the pavements uh
and
i remember we were just throwing
snowballs and
one [ __ ] right you you know you have
like the snowballs and some you you
the common courtesy is you make the
powder snowballs yes of course of course
right of course one [ __ ] decided to
make an ice ball
you know what i mean the ones where it's
like melted ice and you [ __ ] pack it
in and it's on the side of the road yeah
on the side of the road where you just
like
this didn't put a stone in it people
used to do that in my school
seriously i feel like ice balls are like
even worse because you get you get the
you get the hardness of the ice and the
coldness as well which is like numbing
as well it's basically just getting a
cold rock yeah yeah
yeah so i was i was standing right by
the side of the road and
i see the snowball coming and i'm just
like it's a snowball whatever
hits my [ __ ] balls and then i realize
number one
that is perfect aim because it literally
hit my balls
number two that is not a snowball i just
felt
that is a solid ice ball that just came
full force right onto my [ __ ] balls i
i have a really similar story but he
said total opposite it was at the beach
right and uh and my dad and i were at
the beach i think i was like maybe
11 12 years old right and my dad and i
were kicking like the
the rugby ball around and like one thing
i really liked was trying to catch
like the ball that gets kicked really
high up and then you kind of get under
it yeah
like that right so we were doing that a
couple of times i was practicing that
and one time my dad just kicks it really
[ __ ] high up and i was like alright i
got it
sun's in my eyes but i got it i think i
got this and it
comes down it misses my arm and it just
perfectly
flicks my knob
it just flicks out that's the brush
land on my balls it just flicked it like
it went
like that on my knob and i just
collapsed yeah
it was because like i like if if you if
you're not a guy if you're not a male
it's really hard to describe
the pain you feel when your knob gets
flicked or some
and so obviously this happened to me and
i was in total agony
right because your mind just goes blank
so i
i start like walking forwards and i
didn't realize i was walking right into
the middle of a road right because i was
just like i was just like
oh [ __ ] and then
the last thing i remember is my mate go
go what the [ __ ] and he grabs my bag and
pulls me back right everyone pulls me
back and then i just see this [ __ ]
bus just going
right in front of me and uh yeah that
was that was the
that was the closest i've come to dying
i think imagine
dying while grabbing your balls i think
you actually just missed out on your own
isa guy story yeah right
that was your chance that that was one
drop yeah that was that was literally
like
an easter guy origin story yeah i got a
snow i i got an ice ball
i want to watch an instagram story that
literally starts out like that where the
protagonist gets
smashed in the balls and then gets
transported to another world jesus
christ that's scary yeah but
i don't know if i've had any near-death
experiences i had a really stupid
accident one time mm-hmm
we owned like one of those big
trampolines like the uh it's like
the the big ones there's like two sizes
right they're small and then there's a
big one yeah yeah yeah yeah have one of
those
and uh i love doing like front flips
backflips all the works on it
you name it i jumped it right yeah i
jumped it i flipped it yeah
yeah and uh uh one time i was like i'm
just gonna do it on my knees
like i was like practicing like doing
tricks on my knees and one time i just
like
did something landed on my knees and
instead of like
me jumping back my back just went like
like while i was still on my knees
so my back oh jesus like that and i was
like
i've never had this pain in my life i
want to like throw up immediately i
couldn't move oh you just winded
yourself right
i don't know what i did but it was
[ __ ] horrible scared the [ __ ] out of
me
i was so winded and it was oh it was
horrible it was so horrible
god i was like 12 and i was like what's
happening why why do i want to throw up
and oh god oh
my god that must be scary for people
watching you where you you literally
oh you had the trampoline at your house
yeah your parents are like he's probably
having fun on the trampoline
having a trampoline in your house is
great when your friends came over
because you could just [ __ ] fight on
it yeah we didn't have a
backyard big enough for a trampoline
yeah i didn't have that much space yeah
my backyard's pretty big
um well you're a country boy aren't you
what's whales
most people have a pretty decent sized
backyard it's really good though i mean
yeah it's great we just fight on it and
stuff
as you do so in other news uh japan is
back on lockdown
no way we you know what we had a
pleasant
two weeks
what blows my mind is that they they
cancel spectators like
now for the olympics it's starting this
month right yeah like in a couple weeks
yeah what the [ __ ] actually by the time
this is up it's
probably probably started yeah it's
insane to me that they cancelled it
this like the spectators this late when
you know but the athletes are still live
yeah i mean that's that's i mean i get
that but like as if they didn't know how
bad the situation
was it's like whoa [ __ ] didn't get
better suddenly what the [ __ ]
you know it's just to me it's insane
that you know it's also just
irresponsible as well because it's
probably people who booked
hotels you know because even in japan
right you can come from
hokkaido wherever the [ __ ] you are you
can come and watch poor people probably
book time off work maybe probably booked
some hotels yeah they use their limited
like payless
it's like the cyberpunk release but just
like on a scale 10 times that you know
if somebody booked time off work in
japan they ain't playing around no
that doesn't happen like the japanese
government just puts out a tweet which
is just like the [ __ ]
the yellow thing yeah we have delayed
the olympics
we have cancelled spectators we
apologize
i mean it's just yeah unfortunately
you're not we're gonna have to wait even
longer for the new figure episode
because uh we
yeah we're still under a new lockdown
and it just feels like
this entire year has just been a
lockdown but not really for us
it feels like now that the rest of the
world is kind of getting back to normal
it's really weird seeing timelines where
people are having parties and going out
with our masks and stuff and i'm just
here like
yeah this is just this is just life this
is life yeah this is just life now for
us right
it's it's weird because it's like i
don't i know we've talked about this a
lot before but it's because it's such an
ongoing thing and it changes throughout
the time it's like all right restaurants
open
all right okay cool but now they're
close to eight all right okay but now
they consider alcohol okay but now they
can't it's like
what's going on what the [ __ ] is going
on it's just i'm so confused
three no the limit is six the limit is
four yeah yeah
and then it's like all right and then
google maps is completely unreliable now
because now
all the opening and closing times are
[ __ ] live yeah because it's totally
dependent on the place and whether
they're doing it and
most of the time they're not the ones
updating their google page so you don't
even know if shit's open or not
the only thing that has stayed
consistent throughout this entire thing
is that's literally corn only thing that
stayed consistent pretty much
i mean you want to go to a new place now
you check out on google maps oh they're
they're open you turn up at the door
and they're not open and then you try to
find another place and it's just kind of
like playing a roulette wheel
of just seeing what you can do because
it's it's locked down has been really
weird because we say lockdown but it's
just like
you can you can still go out and work
you just can't really
do anything else about that i mean the
trains are still
[ __ ] packed as [ __ ] oh yeah if you
get an eight o'clock train still
you know you're [ __ ] yeah it's you
know you do
you still get squeezed in like that
there will be people pushing you in
still uh during all of this and that's
why a lot of the experts say it's
so worrying uh in tokyo because the
density is insane
yeah you can't you can't just social
distance anywhere in this [ __ ] town
um and yeah did you see that thing with
the tokyo
hotel or something where it was like the
foreigners have to get a different
elevator
from the japanese yeah i saw that i saw
that
classic japanese xenophobia i i heard
that it was a misunderstanding i don't
know if this is true that's what they
all
so i heard this was a misunderstanding
of especially for people who came from a
foreign country
uh right even though realistically right
now
you're probably safer if you've come
from a foreign country
yeah i think that was a lot of the even
though like some people were trying to
defend it being like no no they meant
people who just came in from like
america or whatever you know
and but a lot of people arguing so like
yeah well japan has not handled this
very well i don't think they're in the
place to be able to
you know i don't even think what is this
like less than ten percent of the
populations
got the vaccine right it's something
it's probably higher now but yeah
yeah but i mean still it's like it's
nowhere near where it should be
considering the olympics
to me it just seems like why not just
socially distance in general
in the elevator why not just let two
people go in at a time on the opposite
end why
have to make it like the distinction it
just yeah i don't know it's uh
i mean they could be that's just japan
is just a little
you know the thing that sucks about
japan is that they're just a little too
quick on the decision to make it harsh
on
with making foreign rules they're always
like a little too
like it's like something it's like is
something wrong it's the foreigners
they're just a little it's just it's
just the speed at which they'll be like
maybe we should just maybe just
discriminate a little bit
i'm feeling a little discriminated for
it today it's like the image of that guy
falls off the bicycle and she's like
oh it's the foreigner you know i
at the one time you know they people do
try and justify it and all that but
it's just the ease at which sometimes
japan does it
which bothers me the most like we had
that thing from uh the
i think did you talk about the podcast
the ibaraki prefecture uh
i don't think we haven't talked about
that yeah
prefecture uh gave a warning out for
people not to interact with foreigners
that's right yeah that was one of their
ones oh yeah yeah yeah
foreigners um i think again people
defended some people found it being like
well
they only have people from a foreign
country but there's no way for japanese
people to be able to distinguish between
persons who came from a foreign country
recently yeah it was very obvious what
they were trying to say
uh which was just stay away from
foreigners yeah you know which uh
i mean it's it's it's like the massive
yikes if if this happened in literally
any other country they'd just be called
out for it right right you know and by
by everyone yeah i mean luckily though
in a sense like at least what i've seen
on social media
they have been called out yeah that's
why they're so quick to retract and
being like oh no it was a
misunderstanding
it was it was retracted very fast and i
mean you can imagine why
yeah yeah it's supposed to be very it's
an inferior the hotel is
like quite a uh what's it notable
hotel it's a big friend it's a big big
it's generally an expensive change yeah
is it an expensive chain yeah the tokyo
hotel is a very lightweight it's hard
oh i didn't i thought it was just like
this really it's a premium hotel like
excessive
and you know normally for rich tourists
it's like if the hilton was like no
asians yeah it's that level
it's you know so uh it's just uh
sad very sad yeah yeah
i forgot what i was going to say
something i had a really good point but
i [ __ ] forgot
i'm dumb must have been a good point it
was such a riveting point but
oh well lost the time yeah oh well i
mean i mean it's just like it's
you know obviously we're grateful to be
here but it's just it's weird that
we it's it's not exactly that we feel
discriminated against
obviously it's just sometimes there's
just like a lot of little things that we
see
and we feel and obviously hearing news
like this it kind of like adds to that
little by little yeah i mean when i
speak to someone my age i've never ever
felt
that in japan at all i just feel that
the government and like almost in every
country it's just yeah
all the people kind of out of touch yeah
really yeah i feel like
but i feel it's especially relevant in
japan because again the older
populations gosh
the majority right yeah the difference
is that that's totally fine because
that's what the voters want
exactly literally all the voters
i mean wasn't it like one of the people
on the jab on the olympic committee
like just saying that women women
shouldn't talk
and just stay in the kitchen or
something like that there was something
it was something along the lines of
women shouldn't be allowed to talk at
meetings because
they talk to you they talk oh that was
it yeah yeah at the olympic olympic
meetings
like that's what dudes in the 50s used
to say to their wives
but that was the ex-prime minister of
japan was it it was the
he was the prime minister of japan as
far as i'm aware can you google it to
confirm that but as far as i know it's
the ex-prime minister of japan which
is just very telling um
i'm not saying you know the uk is much
better we're [ __ ] awful
yeah yeah uh but again they're they're
very quick to get called out by it but
then people calling out the
japanese government for a lot of this
stuff you know a lot of the time is the
younger people who are doing it like the
yeah
elderly the social media generation yeah
it was the ex prime minister of japan
but he's also he's also like what 91
years old or something
and he's the [ __ ] like i'm not being
funny but no one 91 years old should be
making countries
i just i think at that point you were
just so far out of touch with the
country yeah absolutely you you can't
like
yeah i mean i mean it's just like at
that point you don't
really i mean you're 91 right why would
you care to change
for society because you know at that
point you already know who you are
you're not going to put in the effort to
change exactly um and
it's just yeah at that point you
probably shouldn't be running a
yeah a country you know i mean like what
joe ben like 70 something but then like
bernie makes me always think like damn
okay maybe old people maybe they know
what's up
oh yeah i think they forgot
i guess that says
that's not too political in the show
this is probably the most political
we've ever gotten on the show
what's naming politicians
he said the name
yeah i don't know it's one of those
things where it's like i don't know it's
just
yeah they're a little too comfortable
with uh dishing that [ __ ] out
that then like whenever i hear stories
like that there's a part of me that
hears that kind of stuff happening and
just makes me wish that young people in
japan were a little more politically
interested
yeah they pretty much have no interest
absolutely or even if they do they don't
they don't
talk about it no one talks about it
publicly barely anyone has any interest
no one believes in the government here
they're just like yeah whatever they're
just doing their thing yeah as long as
we're not in a war with another country
we're good yeah the consensus seems to
be from what i've speak to people is
that they're like oh i don't care as
long as they don't like ruin my life
there's a lot of young people who don't
even know who the prime minister is yeah
wow
yeah it just it just goes to show like
they're that out of touch but in japan
you don't get to choose the prime
minister no you choose the party and
then they choose the prime minister
whereas you know i think that's
technically the same in the uk but it's
not done like that at all we promised
who the person is when we're voting and
that's how it is yeah
yeah you wrote for the party uh and you
don't get to say who they pick
but again it's like i've talked to young
people you know some same age a little
a little bit younger and there's a lot
of them who don't even know what the
political parties are or what they do
they're just not
interested in it whatsoever and it's
like i kind of get the vibe
that everyone is just like so overworked
that they don't
have time to care it's the last thing i
want to worry about
it's pretty it's that's pretty much the
vibe i get is like everyone's just
[ __ ] fighting for the life here as it
is
you know everyone's just trying to get
through the day they don't they don't
have time to care about
other other issues a lot of the time i
remember when they like raised the gst
from eight percent to ten percent
and there was like all these like mobs i
saw that there's all these mobs of all
these old people
how [ __ ] dare you me all the young
people like understandable have a nice
day i'll just work harder
it's like they just don't care it's just
like oh they made a new law
sick i guess i'm just gonna have to mold
my life around this new law now
yeah did you what was this speaking of
dumb japanese laws
you can be arrested in japan if you uh
mod uh games like save files
yeah that sounds all right can
arrested and fined 65 000 pounds
about uh about a k in dollars um
for selling breath of the wild save
files that were modded
seriously yeah no check and apparently
like i've read about it apparently one
of the main reasons why this law was
passed was uh
because guess which company pushed for
it nintendo
yeah of course they did but obviously
they tried obviously that [ __ ] just
america's like lamar no
they're not passing that law in america
yeah yeah because you have the right to
do whatever you want with the products
you buy
yeah yeah but yeah nintendo somehow
managed to very much push for something
to be fair like i think
the selling part was the problem right
like if you just like put it on
but it's also it's also illegal to even
modder switch oh yeah yeah
you can't mod a switch but i think it
isn't it technically illegal everywhere
to mod a switch or no no no
so in the us it's counted as you
bought a product and you're allowed to
do whatever you want with that product
okay
you can you can do whatever you want so
what's the illegal part then buying the
games
getting the games apparently so i i
think the way they managed to pass the
law is that like it's still like an
ongoing
thing like a service you don't actually
own the game right you own a copy of the
game
and by changing it you're like ruining
or
if you buy a nintendo product nintendo
owns you it's insane
there is no escape you know like it's uh
didn't
apple try i don't know if it's illegal
and again can you check it if it's
illegal to jailbreak your phone
i can't i'm pretty sure it's not a i
think it is
i think it's in every country i don't
know is is it or does it just break
warranty
i don't know i thought i thought it just
broke warranty in the uk i can't
remember though
it definitely at least breaks warrant
yeah i know that
yeah every everyone knows that but uh
generally that's what the [ __ ] you want
with the stuff you own
i've never heard of anyone getting
arrested for jailbreaking well to me i
mean
just the idea of a like a [ __ ] a raid
going on
like into some guy's house like get down
stop drop the legend of zelda copies put
them on the floor
and you know in japan right the thing is
in japan right boys rock up with hazmat
when they arrest people in japan they
don't arrest you with two people they
send like 20 [ __ ] police officers in
japan when they arrested
the boys down man they go they got the
whole squad coming
overall it's breaking your iphone's
warrant yeah yeah yeah it's absolutely
guaranteed
i think it differs between the country
but in terms of like apple it's like
they're not going to [ __ ] sue you for
doing it yeah yeah so it's just your
warranty
yeah that's yeah that's but i mean
that's understanding well most products
do that like hey if you [ __ ] change
this thing
we're not going to fix it for you if you
break a seal that says this
breaking the ceo breaks the warranty
then generally you know that breaks the
warranty right
yeah but then i feel you know you also
have to understand that japan
is you know falling a little bit short
on most
common sense laws like uh fair use for
example yeah i mean
i mean failures just isn't the thing
here just seeing
all these videos of like nintendo fans
playing with nintendo to like change
their mind and then like after living
here i'm like dude
it's it's it's not going to happen
that's not how it rolls
yeah it's like us pleading with nintendo
is not going to [ __ ] do anything
unless you should start unless you're in
the start-up
let's get them to change the law unless
unless you are unless you are
uh fully 100 japanese and in that
boardroom meeting with them
it isn't going to matter are miami it's
not gonna change yeah
definitely like coming coming to live
here and seeing how it works on the
inside i'm just like
yeah it's a lot of like no matter how
much noise gets made on twitter i think
most of the time it's gonna fall on deaf
ears yeah so
the way that i just i've come to realize
at least from
living here you can say anything you
want over an email you can explain
everything as well as you want through a
different person but unless
there is a japanese guy there in the
room yeah at the board meeting
explaining something directly to the
person it will not get
yeah you can't have a zoom call no you
can't send an email
you can't send an angry tweet you know
you know you can [ __ ] ratio the [ __ ]
out of nintendo they'll be like
i don't give a [ __ ] you know you know
you need to have someone there
explaining to the person
in person speaking fluent japanese and
possibly having a japanese passport
before they take anything seriously and
even then it's like uh so what company
do you work for who are your backers who
are you representing
yeah you know i've worked at places
where i've wanted to shoot there and
i've had a friend tell them who wasn't
japanese hey can we shoot that and
they're like no i don't know about it
but then you have a japanese person do
the exact same thing like if cajo
hits them up and it's like hey here's
what we're doing and then like oh okay
sure yeah
it's like what it's just like they don't
believe you like i think you're lying
because you're not japanese like you
don't understand you don't understand
how sneaky foreigners trying to
get around our ways it's yeah it's it's
bizarre it's really strange but
this is the way that it's like business
is done here like
and it's and you know it makes it makes
so much sense now why
these companies do this [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] i'm like oh
i totally get it and i'm i'm kind of
like sitting in that halfway point right
because like if i don't open my mouth
they'll be like this [ __ ]
the moment foreign open my mouth they're
like oh you're nihongo nihongo jose
yeah all right let's do it i'm just like
all right let's do business yeah right
let's do exactly i rock up let's do
business no you're a foreigner
jk i am nihongo jose actually and
they're like all right i'm sorry all
right
let's do some business i'm like it's
it's so [ __ ]
embarrassing yeah yeah and i feel like
companies in japan are very
very um what's the word
they very much stick to the hierarchy of
decisions yeah and if you're not
if you're not like the same level you
you can't comment are you talking about
the pyramid the pyramids the pyramids
well like if you're if you're not like
if you're not in that like that that
meeting
your opinion doesn't matter no matter
who you talk to right so i feel like
when people are like all right even if
like
i don't know because nintendo has a
nintendo america i i'd love to know how
much nintendo of america has a say over
what
nintendo the japan officers i feel like
probably not a lot i feel like people
would
yeah i think it's probably not a lot
just based off like what i've seen from
other companies here where you'd think
that they would have an input but they
don't yeah
it's doug bowser is like uh so can we
change this thing and they're like
but we're in a zoom call yeah you're not
in the office
i don't know about that i don't know
again it's all speculation but i imagine
it's
if any from what i've seen here it's
very difficult to get things done if
you're not like
yeah so basically like the longer i live
in japan the more
respect i have for suzaku and code geass
because you watch code gyasa and
everyone wants to be right
everyone wants to be the [ __ ] lelouch
bring down the system
[ __ ] the corporations but then i'm just
like yo suzaku is out there working his
[ __ ] ass off to change it man
like he's the real one he's the real one
climbing that pyramid
he's driving the hierarchy man if if if
this was irl suzaku would still be a
[ __ ]
grunt yeah you don't get
he's like well what do you mean you're
22 no promotion yeah do you have work
experience uh
then stay the [ __ ] down oh you're an
honorary britannian
no no what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is an
honorary britannia
you're not one of the points he wasn't
even like yeah yeah there's no way
he's the guy who changes the vending
machine come on
they wouldn't let him gone had to pee so
uh we're back
[Music]
what have you been up to how was your
pee it was great it was great
that's uh yeah i mean speaking about the
rest of
the world healing um it's it's getting
to the point now where i
kind of meet a lot of people that are
planning their journeys home and that
includes us as well
as connor at least yeah you two are and
uh yeah i'm uh you know what
you know i was missing the other day and
i i know i must be [ __ ] mental
what i was missing a pub i'm just like
why would you watch what's wrong with
that pups are great
i mean i've talked about how i've talked
about that there's no [ __ ] but i mean
i've talked about how like pubs are like
[ __ ] idiots so like
it isn't like crosstalk and god thinks
the architecture here is great you know
i mean
god is a fake british person maybe yeah
he's thai
yeah i'm an honorary britannian
i just had this overwhelming like urge
to go to a [ __ ] weather spoons and
i'm just like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with me
wow every week you should get that urge
yeah moment friday takes over you're
like [ __ ] i wanna i want the curry club
and a pint it's great you can get like a
curry a whole curry meal
and uh a full pint of your alcohol of
choice
like 10 bucks damn and then friday's
pretty good fish and chips fridays as
well
you know
now you're speaking my language yeah
yeah i don't know like i'm like now that
we are in the process of being able to
go back to our countries it's just like
it's it feels good and it feels like i
i get to like kind of look forward to
all the things that have
made me feel kind of homesick i think
because i didn't think i would feel too
homesick about england
until kind of moved out of it and
couldn't go back for a while
i think i think this like lockdown or
pandemic has definitely proven to people
that are like oh
maybe i am homesick just give me enough
time and i'll call you homesick
first year i was like ah it's all right
it's not that bad yeah i was like well
okay like i can get used to this
yeah and now i'm just like going insane
now i'm like nothing is open i can't
[ __ ] do anything
you can't film any cool videos all the
time every single every single thing is
like
boring [ __ ] yeah and then now i can't i
don't know like
so we're booking our trip home i i don't
even know what the [ __ ] is happening
because every country keeps changing its
mind on what's what's happening yeah
i'm like wait do i book the hotel for a
lot for like how many days does it lock
down like well we might get rid of it
it's like
are you are you getting rid of it like
you tell me if you're getting rid of it
i would like to know right yeah so it's
really difficult right isn't it isn't
that like home quarantine an option
though
uh yeah in the uk yeah in the uk hotel
uh and then japan might be doing uh is
doing
vaccine passports yeah i think that's to
return japan yeah to return to
to return which apparently you can apply
from from the 26th my birthday
yeah which is one of the ultimate
birthdays
as well yeah um so yeah i don't know
what's happening i guess i'll figure it
out what's what's the first thing you're
going to do when you go back to england
yeah that's what i was going to ask as
well yeah
i i i'm go i'm going to go i'm going
straight to the [ __ ] pub
check into the hotel i guess i mean
that's the practical house
yeah yeah but after that after you've
settled down at the hotel room what's
the first thing you want to go to
tesco's yeah get a test actually i want
a [ __ ] meal deal
they'll probably have one of the
airports i'll probably get a meal deal
at the airport tesco's meal deal banging
yeah three pound
[ __ ] dude choice of my favorite sandwich
yeah but if it's the airport it's
probably like seven pound right
i guess that's like four yeah it's just
gonna be so weird going to like
a shop or just a tesco's i genuinely
miss airports
i miss going to an airport i miss
i was chilling at the airport i get to
watch so much [ __ ] when you're on a
flight flight
yeah i've been able to watch tv in so
long because i haven't been on a flight
like you know what i mean you get so
much watching done when you're playing
sure
you know i'm chilling in the lobby
having a coffee like when you when you
finally you've checked in your bags are
in the thing it's
actually kind of chill like that like
hour before your flight i like the
feeling
like i like the feeling of going on a
long-haul flight just knowing because it
kind of like
aside from like the long-haul part of
the flight i just like the feeling of
knowing it feels like i'm going on a
holiday you know
it feels like i'm going away for a while
and it's
there's something about going to to the
airport of like your home country
it just it just feels like it just feels
feels like you know
mum's cooking or something like that it
just feels i don't know it just there's
something about it
because every time i go visit thailand
and i step out and i see like the
thai airport i'm just like i'm getting
all nostalgic
it's just the [ __ ] airport it smells
different every kind of song
no no no no every country smells
different i don't i don't know
why it is i totally get that but like i
s literally i step out of the airport go
to
the top the thai airport has this
certain smell gatwick and heathrow has a
certain smell
and i'm just like i can't describe what
it is but i just
but it just feels comforting and i
didn't know that airports smell
different until you go off the airplane
and you're like damn this
i recognize this i don't know if i'm
like i don't know if this is the talk of
a madman right now
no no i i get that whole smell thing
yeah yeah i don't i
it's it's like when certain smells
trigger i just feel like it's like the
breathability of the country you know
like some what that makes less sense
because when you when you land in like
uh in like japan
depending on which airport you land like
the ad is like stuffy or
like when i landed in san francisco i
was like [ __ ] this s
sucks like i'm breathing in i'm like oh
my god the pollution
of some [ __ ] you're literally just
saying the same thing you see what he
said
smells i'm like pollution level like
tokyo how can you tell the pollution
levels
when you breathe in do you not have can
you not like
breathe the quality of air you can't
tell i i can yeah but i can't do it i
can't do it at different [ __ ]
airports i can
when i land in the [ __ ] country i
step off the plane i take a deep breath
and i'm like this ass [ __ ]
[Laughter]
why is this insane it's like you called
me the [ __ ] insane
it's
it literally sounds like the stupidest
superpower
like when i when i watch i can tell
pollution levels in the air i breathe
l.a has horrible air and san francisco
had most big cities have horrible air
oh it depends like that's what makes up
this
i can't tell like the air pollution
differing from like most cities you i
mean
like for example there's a difference
between bangkok and like tokyo is awful
tokyo is turkish that guy's fine it's
fine
what are you talking you don't know
because you've been here too long what
are you talking about what are you
talking about it's like chocolate is
fine
it is not it tastes like [ __ ] bro
breathe it in i don't like the smell i
don't like the
taste
you're literally surrounded by i landed
i landed in singapore airport and i was
like this is a really pretty airplane
that's why
it smells like that's why the airport
has so much plants it's the first breath
it lies to you so you think oh it's
actually good then you leave the
the plant [ __ ] because i've seen
their airports that's just full of
plants and [ __ ] yeah
it's out of every airport i've been to
singapore airport is by far the best
[ __ ] airport
and i have no idea why the singaporean
airport
which country is the best tasting air
upon landing in my experience so far
amsterdam had the best air when i got
off that plane i was like damn this is
some cleaning yeah i can agree with that
there's some cleaning yeah see even you
can agree i think
when i got in charlotte
i was like get put me back on the
[ __ ] plane i don't know i'm
get me out of here no it's bad enough
i'm in paris let alone having to [ __ ]
breathe this air
i was like that when i landed in jfk oh
my god
i was like you're the new york air
you're like bro i don't even need to
like
i don't even need studies to tell me
this as politically yeah i mean like
that's what i'm saying you can tell when
you get on you get off the plane you
breathe you're like oh that's wrong yeah
but that's the same logic as what god
was saying about it
it's this it smells different to me
maybe it's the same you're always
biased about your hometown airport
you're always biased
i think the uh i guarantee people living
in new york from new york is like jfk
has the best smelling airport because it
smells like home
guaranteed yeah maybe i just don't know
what fresh air is because i'm a city boy
i was saying when i uh when i get the
train from london to wales like
when i step off the train from when the
train opens and i breathe in wales i'm
like holy [ __ ] this is what actual air
tastes like
that's because you're from there though
i'm like whoa so there's probably a bias
yeah because it's like that's
like it's like no it's it's not like
super industrial it's just like there's
just [ __ ] fields everywhere
because me and me and connor were
walking walking to the office and connor
was like
god this air tastes horrible and i'm
just like connor what the [ __ ] tokyo
is great i don't know what you're
talking about what are you on about it's
like a mega city bro the air is [ __ ]
here
forest city the tokyo air is actually
pretty good
could that possibly be the most
wankerish thing that connor said oh the
ass
tastes horrible am i allowed to get this
out of my face
i'm just i'm just saying it doesn't it
doesn't
taste polluted that could probably be
the most privileged thing you could have
said in your life
my air is
[Applause]
connor's mom comes to visit from wales
and he just brings out she just brings
like a jar of air
just like just like connor breathe this
in
what did mail what did melinda write did
she write incest again
she's giving me uh the air quality what
is this the rating
all right let me see it let me see let
me see this
that's [ __ ] let me see this let me
see this let me see oh so phil is
terrible so air quality index
so the higher it is the more polluted it
is okay amsterdam
69 nice
uh san fran is 31. the fact that we've
got the whole [ __ ] office to laugh
number 69. you know san fran
air quality index is 31. no way and then
wales
is 68. this is thrilled doesn't count
trolls are [ __ ] yeah
so that's yeah so basically what what
mailing is saying is that san fran air
quality is
twice as better as whales yeah let's
[ __ ] biased as [ __ ] malian's from san
francisco that's why madeleine pulled
that [ __ ]
she just like came up with a random
number no [ __ ] one she's just
she's like facts don't care about your
feelings maybe maybe they took that out
in some vineyards somewhere whereas
perfect air but
their city is [ __ ] awful
[Laughter]
if you're if you're born and raised in
the city your
uh your nostril hair is longer
do you know that google it google it
what did you get on the next episode of
scientology because your
your uh nostrils need to filter more
[ __ ] so it naturally just grows longer i
get that but where the [ __ ] did you read
that i don't know i just heard it
i read it somewhere it's true look it up
i mean i i believe the logic because
it's just like that's why darlene has
these massive bushes going
she's gonna kill her i'm gonna get a
death after that
while nabby looks it up it's true but
yeah that's uh i don't know why
i heard about that i don't know man yeah
i don't know but there is a research
about it
is there actually research well what
climate helped shape
your nose no well yeah no i get that but
like
hairs type in one i'm still sitting in a
nostril
who woke up one day and was just like
you know what i want to i want to
measure
your hairline my friends nose hairs are
longer than mine these are there has to
be a reason we need to know these things
we don't know enough about the human
body we need to know everything
so we can determine what the [ __ ]
going on i mean
is this like when you were like talking
about [ __ ] mouth breathers and all
that [ __ ]
yeah because like because like that's
having no chin i don't know if this is
like one of those like lies or not
it could be but like in my head it's one
of those things i don't even care this
is [ __ ] it makes sense yeah because
why are you scared because
you were going to the dentist to get
like what not retainers but like the uh
the mouth guard the mouth guard thing
and you were just like i didn't want to
breathe well
generally it's better to breathe through
your nose anyway just for air quality
yeah yeah um
that's the [ __ ] filter through right
all right all right what is it
well there is a steady like
if there are any nose hair experts
watching this uh could you leave it down
in the comments below thank you
well yeah
it would make sense though right if you
were born and you're you were in a place
that was more polluted naturally it
would make sense for your body
well like i feel like there's something
your mum says be like it's a good thing
you're not in the sea right they have
long nose hairs in the sink
you don't have to trim your nose hairs
boy i feel like that was a little
tail i always felt like i had long nose
hair anyway so i'm like [ __ ] imagine if
i was born in the city i'd be
like [ __ ] tarzan's crotch in my nose
so interactive indicator of put air
quality using
nose hair length as a rough metric for
just how much nasal fiber
one would need to catch and filter
harmful particulate matter in aegis over
there but it sounds like i'm right
does it but it's so ridiculous i i
literally stopped listening halfway
through that sentence
but yeah also get that off like wikihow
also i don't know why i started getting
recommended videos about like breathing
from your mouth and i don't know why i
was getting recommended this stuff
but i watched it i watched my other
mouth
i watched it i watched it and it was
like it was it was one of those videos
where it's like
this is this would if i wasn't dumb as
[ __ ] this would be so convincing like
yeah i it felt so manipulative these
videos that they were like look
there's twins one of them was allergic
to hamsters and they had a hamster in
that room
and that thus he couldn't breathe
through his nose and look what happened
to
his chin it's all gross
they just showed like a [ __ ] picture
of leafy or something like that
oh why are you gonna do them like that
that's bullying bro
one of those leafy and the other guys
like well it was like it was like yeah
it was like
one had like a clearly defined chin it's
just like a [ __ ]
one had like a clearly defined chin and
one had like the i don't even know what
you call it it's like the
not really a chin it's kind of like it
leads into it yeah yeah yeah and that's
generally believed to be unattractive
amongst sigma members
i love that as well your chin is like
getting swallowed into your neck kinda
yeah and
it's one of those things where you're
like ha everyone i did meet
who i feel like had that kind of face
did breathe through their mouth i think
and then it's one of those things where
it kind of it builds on your
your just like ignorance of it and your
anecdotal evidence of it right but then
i
you know i saw more videos about it and
i was like you know the more i feel like
it the more the more
this is like feels like some kind of
sigma male [ __ ] this you know what i
mean i felt like i was getting fed but i
don't know how accurate it is because
then i start watching videos about
apparently doctors who specialize in uh
what they'll do is that they'll uh [ __ ]
what they do they'll do something so
that when you sleep or when you normally
do it that you breathe through your
mouth and they go look it's fixed
his chin is [ __ ] normal well they're
just like here's some tape i don't know
put it on your mouth
i don't particularly care to learn more
about it or check how real it was but
now it's in your head
now you're just like but what if i do
breathe but also i generally want to
breathe through my nose anyway because
it's just the whole of you know when you
breathe through your mouth your it isn't
being filtered and [ __ ] and
yeah i i'd like to live as long as i can
so i can be as stubborn as i can for as
long as i can
i mean like maybe i can become a
japanese politician and make life
healthy
full circle i mean i feel like you do
breathe through your nose most of the
time
um you can only tell who the mouth
breathers are because
can you let me finish myself okay
you can only tell who the mouth
breathers are when you're like you're
you're in a hotel room
and there's always the one snorer who is
just like
you you know you know sometimes when
you're like yeah sometimes when you're
really quiet
when when you're really tired but
sometimes you you are with a group of
mates and you know who the [ __ ]
snorer is right yeah and it's like a
[ __ ] time limit
of just like all right i've got
literally half an hour to fall asleep or
i'm not sleeping tonight and
it's and it's not just the snorers right
because there are the snorers that do it
through their nose
and then there are the snores that do it
through there you can tell when people
snore through their mouths yeah yeah
yeah exactly
no it's so weird because like i grew up
breathing through my mouth
so i was a mouth breather when i was
sleeping when i was like
so funny but that's because i had like
horrible hate fever so like my nose is
constantly blocked all the time
it's a pretty good descriptive insult
because i feel like you know as much as
uh
much as i i i wouldn't use it you get a
very good picture of what they're trying
to paint when someone calls you a mouth
breather
[Music]
i definitely became paranoid that i was
breathing through my mouth am i becoming
a male
i remember that i was like i was
[Music]
because i feel like i have a
semi-defined chain i guess i don't know
yeah
semi-defined i don't know i i i haven't
got this
and i was like yeah i did breathe
through my nose as a kid but then again
again it's i feel like it all
goes on anecdotal evidence you know
everything again i don't know how
accurate it is it seemed
it felt like pseudoscience when i was
watching this [ __ ] pretty much
everything
it was enough to make me care even
though i know i shouldn't now you've
made like a lot of people
watching this yeah everyone watching
this can be like oh [ __ ] do whatever i'm
saying
i'm just doing this just like do i have
a chin am i good
am i good isn't it sad that we give a
[ __ ] about chins
i don't care about chin why do we care
about chins i know
did you did your parents ever tell you
like like an old folk tale or something
to get you
to do something as a kid i don't know i
don't know i don't know what japanese
things there are
because in thailand it's like one of the
things is um if you
eat on the bed then
when you're reincarnated in your next
life you're going to reincarnate as a
snake
and i'm just remembering this now
and that was what i was told to not get
me to eat on the bed and
i don't i guess it works because i hate
eating on the bed now japan has
is like infamous for all these like
proverbs and wives like one of them was
like if
you sleep immediately after you eat then
you turn into a cow
oh i think taina did something similar
to that as well yeah
i guess i think my mum stopped telling
me these because whenever my mum told me
them i would immediately go and try them
because
like i remember one time my mom was like
what the [ __ ] you doing i just kept
opening the umbrella indoors i was like
i want to see if something bad happens
yeah so i just kept opening yeah yeah
yeah
and nothing happened yeah i was like oh
nice well that's the thing it's like
some japanese proverbs are based on like
actual like facts that are harmful to
your body like so
so the sleeping after you eat thing is
actually has a little bit of logic to it
because like if you do sleep immediately
after you eat then all the gastric
stuff goes up your software and it makes
me your esophagus and like
damages your throat so i'm like oh okay
so there's actual reasoning behind that
that's good but then there are some
which just like
are reserved don't whistle at night
because snakes will come and i'm like
snakes are
literally death oh that sounds amazing
no
it isn't from the music it's from the
movement yeah from the vibrations yeah
right
the movements it's literally the
movement of this yeah the movement of
the guy that they follow
how did snake charms like start life
i could believe they just wake up one
day they're like you know what i want to
charm some snakes
i got a flute got a basket white people
stop stupid
i don't know do snapchamas even exist
anymore
i you don't really charm them do you
just make them dance a little bit right
but like is that like
a thing that's like is there a person
out there somewhere in the world that's
like yes i am a professional snake charm
probably it's probably a mouth breather
why why you're obsessed with that word
now that you've told me it's an insult
i'm just like
if there's [ __ ] psychics out there
that can be any job i don't really give
a [ __ ] i just feel though it's like one
of those
like pseudo occupations that were kind
of very timely back in that
it's like you know like a soothsayer
right like no one goes around being like
i'm a professional soothsayer
they're just like saying they're just
like budget magicians yeah what is that
actually a suit says like a person who
goes around and like tells fortunes and
like tells your future and stuff oh
that's a little
[ __ ] i mean like a fortune teller like
kind of yeah that's an occupation
sounds way cooler that that's an
occupation that should have gone out of
business
i think it did go out it's fortune
telling unfortunately yeah how that
should still exist i don't know i i
have friends who do who do that and i'm
just like you're a [ __ ] idiot oh
really yeah
it's like the what the crystal ball or
the turret cards all like read their
hands and stuff
oh stuff right yeah
yeah i'm like have you seen some of the
fish out there like do you think god
really gave enough of a [ __ ] to worry
about right putting [ __ ]
inscriptions on your hand of what your
life's gonna be like man couldn't even
finish half the [ __ ] fishes in the
ocean
are you serious bro come on no no he did
not he did not inscribe he didn't give a
[ __ ] about you
i mean i like doing it every now and
then just to see what they say
it we like to feel interesting as people
yeah that's an egotistical need that we
have
but i genuinely believe that we are not
interesting things
it is up to us to make our own lives
interesting and horoscopes and all that
and all that nonsense i just don't
believe in any of it because i'm like
nobody gives gives a [ __ ] about this you
don't believe in like star signs or
anything like that no
honestly i don't mean either
[Laughter]
like the whole like the whole thing me
either the whole blood type
cold blood type the whole uh lines on
your hands all of that [ __ ] i believe i
just think it's [ __ ] nice
i i think it's cool and i and when
someone tells me i'll listen i think
it's cool for the sake of entertainment
yeah i i i view as more just like an
entertaining thing as or like a
conversation starter right yeah
yeah it's not something i take seriously
but i'm like is your life so [ __ ]
boring well this is the thing that gets
you excited this is what you look
forward to like
you need you need lies to tell yourself
to to to feel like you're doing
something in life
don't [ __ ] do something some people
need that man some people need that
encouragement
wow go and do something stop reading
your [ __ ] hands only mouth breathers
do that
the reason why you have no [ __ ] is not
because of it lying in your hand okay
it's because he breathes through your
mouth
like [ __ ] [ __ ] reading your hands but
please breathe through your mouth yeah
that's real
i i you know i think that you could like
there is behavior that you can do that
can affect
your health and your body yeah yeah
that's that's i feel like that's fair to
say
yeah i mean like i think that no no
mystical entity
decided to carve some [ __ ] lines in
your hand and that that would decide how
your personality was gonna be no [ __ ] no
no i mean yeah there is there is a clear
difference because
i feel like there is a lot of little
things you just don't know about your
body
and then you don't figure it out until
you hit like 30 or something yeah
and then you realize oh we also don't
know a lot of stuff about the human body
we have like we're still like barely
understanding how the mind works you
know yeah
yeah yeah i mean we we're still like
[ __ ] decades and centuries after
like figuring out how that works but in
terms of all of america doesn't even
have bidets so how the [ __ ] are they
gonna
have scientific breakthroughs yeah i
don't believe that you can't have a
scientific breakthrough not with a baby
call themselves a first world country
yeah you're not having any good days if
they ever figured that out how the [ __ ]
they're going to figure out what's going
on in the brain sorry go ahead calm
i completely was good i forgot what i
was going to say i'm not saying that
they haven't discovered anything about
the brain
um no it's just like like part of like
growing up and growing into like your
30s i guess is just realizing that
sometimes you just have a problem with
your body and like as a kid i thought
everything's fixable everything will go
back to normal eventually yeah and then
you don't realize that sometimes you
just have a problem
and then you just you just learn to live
with it i guess it's pretty
sad like it's like kind of hope that you
don't get a problem that's
too much yeah yeah like kidney stones
[ __ ] if i get those
[ __ ] oh yeah like everyone everyone
around my age just starts talking about
their knees and luckily enough i haven't
felt
anything about my knees yet but like
lower back pain knees
like neck pain headaches it's just it's
just like god decided all right
everyone gets a debuff at 30. everyone
gets a different one
you know it's like the moment you turn
30 just god comes to your sleep
yeah i don't know i watched that video
of uh what was it
it's probably it was probably on your
guys recommended it as well of like how
do kidneys
i was gonna watch that i i had it on the
watch later i never did yeah
because a super interesting video i
recommend it but it's like
explain it to me basically it's this guy
who uh he got big off tick tock i think
because he's like uh
he's like works in forensics or
something but basically he
uses like the bodies that you know you
donate to science and
to study things about the human body
basically yeah and uh and this guy got
really big on tick tock i've got his
name
basically just doing short videos of
like did you know that this is this is a
real stomach i'm gonna open it up and
show you
how food is digested or whatever and he
has a youtube channel
and he literally gets like a real human
body that like
whether he's getting people people don't
in their bodies to science after that
okay yeah yeah he works in like some
kind of like
scientific research dexter or something
like that
he's one i dug up earlier it's like the
modern day dexter
it's nice he's not a forensics expert
he's just a tick-tock
has anyone has anyone checked the
scottish credentials
he gets like a proper human body and
like opens up the kidneys and like
explains how kidney stones form and why
they [ __ ] hurt and stuff and it's
like
man i can't imagine something that big
traveling through my dick that how big
is it
some of these are big some of these can
go like that but you have to just hope
they break down
in your kidneys like because they just
can't go through the tubes right these
ultrasound uh
ultrasonic ultrasonic yeah yeah and
you're like your kidneys to break it
they literally they literally scream at
it to like crumble
essentially screams
but in worst case scenarios where like
not even that works that it's so
crystallizing so hard they literally
go through your penis with like a pair
of tweezers to just pull it out
oh yeah i did not need to hear this oh
yeah i'm sorry i
need i'm sorry yeah this guy institute
of human anatomy that's the guy
yeah really cool tick tock channel
someone sounds like a youtube channel
just hope he's not a serial killer yeah
yeah
i mean he sounds nice i don't want any
tweezers going on my peepee
yeah i i can't i i literally can't
handle like hospitals at all i just like
faint immediately
that's that's why i'm like really
nervous to get older because you have to
do
you know when you hit like a certain age
you have to do that yeah annual
colonoscopy and you're like that's
like i'm just not looking forward to the
day where a camera has to go up my ass
late
hospitals are probably the only fear
that i have that i i think is like
irrational i guess is i guess is that
what it counts as well because lots of
bad stuff happened in hospitals right
it's just like i know that shit's gonna
happen in my body i'm not used to it i
don't like it i don't like anything and
i just i always like get so light-headed
to my phone
it's horrible you scared of needles or
anything like that no i don't give a
[ __ ] about needles it's like operations
and stuff terrify me
yeah it's just it's just things entering
my body that shouldn't be there
yeah even like when i went to the
dentist the other day like just having
like the [ __ ] [ __ ] in my mouth like
[ __ ] loud as [ __ ] yeah yeah i was
getting light-headed i was like [ __ ]
i mean that's why everyone hates going
to the dentist because like you hear
sounds
in your mouth that just shouldn't be
made anywhere near it's weird because i
didn't give a [ __ ] as a kid i really
i didn't care at all when i had to go
and do that stuff but i don't know what
happened
between like after age 18 where i
suddenly started being terrified of it
i'm not really sure why
like i can barely give myself eye drops
let alone something going into my body
you have that friend who's had like 10
surgeries
yeah right i'm like how the [ __ ] are you
doing this how are you not like [ __ ]
freaking out
right maybe they are i don't know it's
like when my dad comes back from his
annual colonoscopy right it's just like
you know it's it's it's it's the same
it's like yeah i just went to the park
legit would faint yeah right
how do i tell the doctor listen i'm a
little [ __ ] bro i don't know what's
gonna happen like
yeah like i'm gonna loop me up or
something i don't know yeah yeah like
i'm lucky enough to like have never
needed to have surgery or anything like
that but just like the concept of it
[ __ ]
terrifies me that that's that's one
that's one thing that [ __ ] even if it's
not
life-threatening surgery you know it's
like like the the the whole idea of
being under anesthesia just like
terrifies me oh no
i hate the surgeries where you're not on
it yeah or you're on light one like the
surgeries when
like uh i think my parents my mom had
something with a heart and she had to be
awake for it and that
sounded terrifying what yeah because
apparently i i don't know it sounded
awful like yeah
apparently you can feel it and stuff
yeah it's terrible imagine like you can
yeah yeah exactly right horrible
but if you have to have it you have to
have it right but i think i think
maybe it came from uh i had to get
because i had hemophilia where i'd like
if i bleed i you know don't stop
bleeding i had to go like every
three or six months to the hospital yeah
to go and do tests just to make sure it
wasn't getting worse or getting any
better luckily it didn't get any worse
uh but uh yeah it was awful i hated
going and i would
it was just like a terrible experience
because i think it's because of what
like the atmosphere in a hospital oh
yeah dude yeah yeah yeah hospital
atmosphere so
the ward that i'd always have to go to
was just filled with like old people
that were like dying
yeah and like some of them couldn't like
even like think or talk and it was i
felt so bad because they would talk to
me and they just didn't understand they
scared the [ __ ] out of me i was like 13.
oh yeah yeah i was like oh my god
not jesus yeah because it's like it's
it's that like glimpse into a possible
future
oh [ __ ] i could be like that one day
yeah and the smell
yeah they're talking about smells
hospitals do definitely have a
distinction
oh those are even like thinking about
the smell makes you uncomfortable
that's what i hate about the dentist as
well like the dentist has that like type
of smell that's like
oh what is that i don't know that's why
when you get it
then dentists smell sanitized i don't
know so
when you like it's like it's overly
sanitized you know where it's like this
is too
yeah it's like you just stepped into a
crime scene yeah just like oh man
but like it's everything's bleached yeah
everything's bleached to [ __ ] i hate it
when the doctor like doesn't talk at all
doesn't like crack jokes or anything
i like it because like when the nurse
when the nurse is like funny as [ __ ] i
feel so good i feel like
i'm chill the nurse is like cracking
jerks she's like yeah i do this all the
[ __ ] time
and she's like tell me about funny old
other patients and stuff i feel so more
at ease
when the doctor doesn't say anything i'm
like what's going on talk to me what's
going on yeah where the doctor doesn't
smile or anything like that yeah i'm
like whoa what's going on bro yeah come
on tell me
i know you're being serious with your
job but you know help me calm down a
little bit dude it's like
[ __ ] hell it's like we're at a job
interview yeah
i remember there was only one time i
ever wanted to go to the hospital and it
was uh
this one specific hospital that i think
i went to one time had uh
a gamecube right when it came out and i
was like what is this mythical hospital
right yeah but why don't more hospitals
do that and i was like all right next i
saw it and i was like
i saw it as i was leaving i was like
next time i'm coming i'm gonna play it
and then i went
and someone [ __ ] stole the
controllers so they had a game shoot a
gamecube with no no
they're like super mario sunshine super
mario strikers super mario party brawl
they ball somehow
that's where you could even buy that
game often like yeah why did they have
this at a hospital
i think it was like a charity had given
them a donated there's like a a
room where it was like it was when i was
like 12 so yeah kids
but so that makes me awesome some
[ __ ] rules even worse some [ __ ]
[ __ ] stole a [ __ ] gamecube
controller
from a children's hospital that have
been donating from a charity
what who does that who does that
i hope it's only a mouth where he looks
i hope it's another chicken
we're gonna get in trouble i don't know
if this is a controversial incident
controversial
i just can't take that insult seriously
anymore apparently it's a
it was an insult back in the 1940s 40s
america
so 40s jesus christ
this is the first i'm hearing of it this
is like this is like if i taught you the
word blessing you found out it was
racist or something
like [ __ ] i've been saying the whole
episode jesus christ i i want to know
the motivation if somebody steals a
gamecube controller from a
that's all it was already a rare console
at the time honestly it's probably
another kid right it's probably another
kid i imagine it was another kid who
just
doesn't have a gamecube always wanting a
game or they stole a gamecube from
somewhere i forgot the controllers
yeah how are you like because gamecubes
at that time i think were quite
expensive
and they were i mean the games weren't
cheap because it's nintendo yeah so i
mean the game's us
you're rich enough where your parents
buy your gamecube but not enough
controllers so you steal it from a kid's
hospital
like what what an arsenal yeah i don't
know really strange really bizarre
[ __ ] that kid i was so excited to play
[ __ ] brawlers
what are you in the hospital for yeah i
don't know i was getting checkups i
think
you're like mom mom can we go to the
hospital please mom
i know i went to the hospital a lot i
know i had a lot of i think injuries but
all of them ended up being like just
chill ones just like
whatever it's like sprains like not
nothing luckily i just never broke bones
so
wow yeah i don't know how i got so lucky
because i [ __ ] my body up so many
times i don't know how i got so lucky
it's like why is my kid so enthusiastic
to go to the hospital
yeah and also sometimes you get like
your parents would like buy you like a
sweet or something afterwards they'd be
like yeah you get some like nice food
because you're all hospital i thought
when you said sweet i thought you meant
like a hotel
you're too adult jay are you they bought
me a sweet we call them sweets in the uk
oh okay well if you buy like chocolate
all that it's like sweets do you know
what we call them in australia
oh yeah no no no we have we if they're
lollipops yeah do you would you photo
all candies
all candy along oh so we refer to
lollies as just lollipops yeah yeah yeah
but in australia they're all called
lollies there's an infamous like meme
photo of me from like
back in the day where i'm at australia
i'm at an airport in sydney and
i just thought it was really funny i
just posed next to this sign that just
said bagged lollies and i just like
just did that and it's like made its
rounds on like mean
i'm glad that the lollipop is the worst
candy of all time
it is now i can say i hate lollies in
every sense
it is no i i remember when i used to get
it at like age 10 they give you a
lollipop you're like for [ __ ] sake
it's the cola flavored [ __ ] lollipop
i like the cola flavored ones [ __ ] that
sucks you mean the chopper chops right
yeah
no [ __ ] off cola flavored sweets are
just not good
they suck it's it's like eating hard
flat coke and that's that's that's the
best way i can describe it
like flat coke is bad enough as it is
let's make it hard
i never liked who liked lollipops they
[ __ ] sucked
i mean i'm not gonna go out of my way to
eat a [ __ ] chopper shops now
yeah now but i won't complain excuse me
it was made to like make kids eat sweets
for a long time that
yeah aren't actually like at a lot of
sweets yeah
i was smart i realized this is waste
this is not optimized i can i can i can
eat way more
i have teeth to break this down yeah i
hated it i'd never go for the lollipops
i think chocolate is the best sweet like
thing yeah but that's often not
considered like candy yeah
it's kind of in its own thing yeah yeah
i really like the um haribo i love
sour haribo were pretty [ __ ] good i
like haribo
um anything oh i like the laces you know
oh
the sour like strips sour laces oh the
sour strips the rainbow sour strips
those things slap i love those in
australia did you have like the penny
sweets
well any sweets yeah we had this in the
uk yeah where you go to like a
literally a [ __ ] candy store and you
get given a bag and you just like fill
it up
oh yes yes yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean
those i i think those [ __ ] candy
slaps oh yeah well we we have
the biggest one in wales is like in my
town and it's literally the size of this
set
that's huge but i mean considering every
single wall is candy
it's good and they used to have these
like really [ __ ] sour things like
like the most sour
sweet in the world yeah yeah they're
just dunked in that [ __ ] horrible
sour stuff you gave us that one video
oh yeah it's just fun i love sour candy
man
yeah sour candy is my favorite but it's
awful though because you can't drink
anything afterwards and waters taste bad
water tastes sweet right yeah i kind of
like that though what i don't know why
it's something about that where it's
like every other drink tastes like
absolutely [ __ ]
yeah but like when the water is sweet
i'm just like oh oh
yeah i mean it's kind of nice yeah i
mean i i don't think it's that bad it's
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] water
it's just water bro i'm too british i
think i like crisps the most
that's my favorite snack walker's crisps
yeah walker's crisps are amazing we have
so many good crisps in the uk
because it's like a national like
identity like every single lunch must
have a bag of christmas not chips
crisps crisps crisps nah they're called
cheers we have so many good brands of
crisps like i [ __ ] love monster munch
i love
mccoys the monster sounds epic do
monster mods
i will say i'll say the best best crisp
i miss
walker's max paprika flavor they're just
mccoy's kind of but like lighter
like mccoy's like thick no no no like
because like
walker's max has like this sound [ __ ]
stupid to any americans
like what are they saying i'm just like
the walkers the walkers max crisps
have like the right amount of like
oiliness to them yeah
it's just it's just like it's a little
it's a little unhealthy it's kind of
weird because like we
give like you know i don't know what the
standard lunch is in australia
or america yeah but like if you ever
have a lunch in the uk it normally just
comes with crisps
it's like a given school lunch
lunches and you come with a bag of
crisps oh yeah um i mean yeah i guess
like
you know i used to
[ __ ] test goes or [ __ ] like you go
to you go to subway yeah there's chris
you go to greg's there's crisps like
it's always like it comes with the lunch
it's such a
staple in the british uh license it's
like salt flavored
or no that we have so many flavors and i
think they're amazing most
i've i've yet to find many brands of
crisps that i don't like in the uk right
like quavers i love quavers
i love even though you have to buy so
quavers have you seen these before
basically like cheese flavored like thin
skulls
right yeah they're cheese flavored but
they're not they don't taste anything
like cheetos
no no it's like a much lighter yeah you
can eat like seven bags in one sitting
no problem because it just tastes like
air
right the whole thing is like it's light
and has like two calories yep it has
like two bites in the bags
yeah that's what it looks like yeah
because like yeah they're [ __ ]
amazing bro
never seen those are okay uh we have
like these
palm bears what are they called they're
in france as well bears yeah like the
bears crisp they're just better
i've never seen them they're really good
what the [ __ ] them they're in europe too
yeah they're german right but the other
british ones the monster munch is my
favorite
chris loves monster munch too i think
and mccoy's he's pretty british though
yeah mccoy's is okay i i still i still
stand by the walker's mouth
let me google british crisps this is so
[ __ ] many i'm like
this is it's been like a [ __ ] tangent
hasn't it yeah
we have so many people all australians
watching this can agree
that the best chips we have is red rock
daily chips that's like the one
that is the one brand that i've seen
since the beginning of my career
i will happily sell out we recently but
about this time
just before i left we recently started
having a boom of like high-end crisps in
the uk
oh you mean the kettle chips yeah chips
tyrells are like massive now yeah yeah
yeah
you sometimes see them in japan they
import them really as like premium
british crisps
there's also french they're called
french fries yeah yeah like do you have
these
i think so they're just like crisps that
are shaped like yeah yeah yeah yeah we
have those
they're really [ __ ] good i don't
think they're called french fries though
there's like a different brand you have
uh
squares by walkers oh squares [ __ ]
okay okay
salty squirts and the salt and vinegar
ones are super [ __ ] salty okay
they have salt and vinegar uh prawn
cocktail and cheese and onion prawn
cocktail
i've realized cheese and onion is a very
like british flavor
[ __ ] cheese is like the best because
we don't have cheese and onion flavored
stuff in australia dude you're missing
out
is honestly like the best
the one brand of chips that i thought
was [ __ ] awesome was when i was in
ireland i had potatoes
potatoes i think that's a specific
island specific to ireland but the
cheese and flavor potatoes
man orgasmic they're so [ __ ] good
but wait yeah wait [ __ ] what was what we
were on before that
squares squares squares squares are
really nice uh we also have
hula hoops all the hoops they have these
in america i'm pretty sure they do
they're just the ones you put on your
they can fit on your fingers they're
like rings oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah we have knickknacks
i really like knickknacks
i never had those people that's a very
like uh like marmalade
coated crisps marmalade right i think
it's what it is
is that what it that sounds weird
what are they called what's it's in
america as well i think they have what's
it like cheetos
yeah they kind of feel like cheetos but
uh
jacob minis are sensations
i remember sensations oh my god they had
like premium
bagged crisps yeah but these are all
like walker's brands right yeah they're
all one
yeah because walkers just like like
walkers is what are they called in
america again
i wish we had this conversation last
week when shu was here because i don't
have another australian to relate to
damn it people have like apparently
there's so many news organizations in
the uk have done
uh tier lists of crisps from like bottom
tier to like heights oh that's a that's
an after dark uh
we also had a bag of crisps that was
really popular
it was called salt and shake that was
like a bag of crisps that we hadn't been
salted and it would come with salt and
the whole gimmick of this thing was that
you put the salt in it
you should shake it up yeah you saw
you'd literally salt it yourself
right right right and it tastes like
[ __ ]
because it was like it was just unsalted
evenly like it was the salt would stick
to like the bottom
and then the rest of the sauce just at
the bottom yeah it was terrible
but like yeah and it's like if you come
to the uk i really highly recommend
trying all our crisps
yeah i don't really rate the japanese
ones too much nah they're pretty bad uh
the pizza potato one's pretty good yeah
that's what i'd say only the pizza
cheese i don't know why you like the
pizza potato ones
yeah i told chris i was like uh next
video that i want to make with him is uh
trying all the japanese crisps
just two [ __ ] super british people
complaining about crisps
because there's a lot of like meh ones
here
most of the ones you find here are just
pretty meh especially the ones in from
like the combination the
flavors they have are so bizarre and
they have doritos here but they're like
taco flavored
and it does not taste like taco well
they have cheetos here as well but it
doesn't taste like
that's not about like pizza flavored
stuff i mean what what is the flavor of
pizza anyway
right it's rust yeah no crust no no no
crust apparently
not a single [ __ ] crust in sight mate
you won't see a crust
you should love it technically there's
no crust i mean it's
not i mean it's a pizza you know a
has a unique pizza it's a pizza you need
the crust in the pizza just not the
crust by itself
it's you hearing this
this man's stuff i'm i'm not i'm not
going to start we're not going to start
talking about [ __ ] pizza crust again
we've moved on we've evolved from that
let's uh let's let's just talk about the
patrons before that when we get on to
that
i mean talking about people who are
definitely not mouth breathers
look at all these all these patreons i
sure i bet it's gonna insult so many
people yeah
i really i really hope there isn't like
a mouth breathing community
on the internet that's just going to
come out but hey if you're not a mouth
breather then
maybe go over to my patreon i'll laugh
if this episode ages
super horribly like a mouthpiece
probably [ __ ] well
i think i was like the next racial
slaughter but yeah but consider
following us on patreon support the show
patreon.com also follow us on twitter
send us your memes on the subreddit and
if you hate our faces listen to us on
spotify
but uh yeah i'm literally googling right
now is mouth breathers offensive
it doesn't matter because the way gaunt
said it sounded a little too cozy you
know you got a little two columns
hard m on the word mouth there i don't i
don't like the way you inflicted that
well but hope you enjoyed this episode
of trash taste
i'll see you guys next week
it says be called mouth breather used is
used as a derogatory term
used to describe someone who is well
here's the urban dictionary definition
literally someone who likes enough
intelligence that they ever looked that
they never learned
to breathe through their nose
all right well that's been this episode
of trash turn on that bombshell good
night
[Music]
you